angelina jolie just scored a major
victory in her ongoing custody battle
with brad pitt
e.t has learned the court has
disqualified the private judge that was
on the case
meaning the court agreed with angelina's
appeal that judge
john w outerkirk did not sufficiently
disclose business relationships with
brad's attorneys
so what does this mean basically that
the custody battle over the couple's
five minor children
could be starting over it's important to
note that brad or the judge
could appeal this decision and brad's
rep tells et
of this ruling quote the appeals court
ruling was based on a technical
procedural issue
but the facts haven't changed there is
an extraordinary amount of factual
evidence which led the judge
and the many experts who testified to
reach their clear conclusion about what
is in the children's best interest
we will continue to do what's necessary
illegally based on those detailed
findings
of what's best for the children i think
about everything i do now my kids are
going to see when they grow up and how
are they going to feel but they
they know me as a dad brad and angelina
first filed for divorce in 2016
and while the court has ruled them
divorced their child's custody case has
been its own
separate case and ongoing for quite some
time
this past march in a possible effort to
gain full custody or alter their custody
agreement
angelina claimed to have proof of
alleged domestic violence against brad
from the register i believe that
angelina jolie is seeking
custody orders and in support of those
custody orders she's alleging domestic
violence
at the time et spoke to kelly chang
rickert a certified family law
specialist
to help explain domestic violence is a
serious charge in family law
so many people who use this are trying
to seek
sole custody brad was cleared of
allegations of child abuse by both
the fbi and the department of child and
family services back in 2016.
a source at the time told et brad was
heartbroken by the claim
brangelina's full custody agreement is
not currently public knowledge
the case is sealed earlier this year e.t
spoke to angelina who
opened up about working through tough
times well we all have
times in our lives where we feel broken
and uh i was in a period like that
it's been you know i've had my
my share of of things that have made me
feel um
you know hard to speak too much about it
but just overwhelmed
or broken
you